hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easy german wir
sind wieder in berlin und bayern slams
wir erinnert euch wahrscheinlich an lens
er war schon mal vor kurzem bei uns
brennt was fragst du heute die menschen
auf der straße ich frage was bedeutet
kurs für sie persönlich war und warum
stellst du diese frage lenz weil ich
kunst studiert habe und weil es ein
herzliches oder herzen thema von mir ist
ein herzensthema von dir lenz dann habe
ich direkt meine frage an dich was ist
denn kunst für dich was bedeutet es für
dich
gute frage kunst für mich ist eine
interpretation der erfahrung
das heißt das wird heute auch vielleicht
ein bisschen der philosophische frage ja
wir sind gespannt ihr geht jetzt zur
museumsinsel
hier ist ein mikrofon dankeschön los
geht's
eine kurze frage was bedeutet kunst für
sie kunst und es ist keine kurze frage
ist eine lange antwort ist alles glaube
ich überall kann man sehen und hören
wenn sie kunst
kann ich so nicht definieren weil kunst
ist ja alles was nichts mit nützlichen
dingen für uns bedeutet für mich leben
alltag besonderes
ganz ganz viel
äußerer ausdruck einer verfassung oder
einer stimmung oder irgendeiner schwer
auszudrücken sache auf besondere art und
weise
mehr fällt mir dazu nicht ein kunst für
mich bedeutet sie hätte es ein fax
kreative kreative art zur geltung bringt
die frage jetzt kommt weil wir hier vor
einem museum der sonne heute waren wir
nicht im museum
was bedeutet kunst für mich persönlich
was schönes was ich mir anschauen kann
um mich dann auch freuen kann das ist
für mich kunst irgendwas was im
gedächtnis zurück bleibt und eine spur
hinterlässt das ist für mich kunst kunst
ist im besten sinne das was nicht
natürlich ist was der mensch sich
schafft ja weil mit weil er mit der
natur nicht zufrieden ist also das
reicht ihm nicht
so würde ich sagen und das schafft er
ein kunstwerk das wäre das eine um was
schönes zu schaffen
manche leute um was auszudrücken
aber ich finde diese abgrenzung von
sozusagen natur und kunst denkt denke
dessen die ganz fundamentalen zwei dinge
im leben
das eines mitmensch das andere ohne
mensch die kunst ist mit milch aber
dogmatiker auch in der kunst wenig
spital eine bereicherung für das leben
deswegen waren wir heute im museum in
der musik
beethoven an erster stelle wer die macht
es mir zu zu schweren oder vielleicht
auch zu sehr kläglich schon wieder
es ist nicht alltägliche geschäft ist
nicht mein ding einfach können sie für
uns etwas empfehlen hier in berlin oder
in deutschland zu zählen jetzt in
richtung kunst oder allgemein kunst oder
ja ich bin da leider nicht so bewandert
also ich gehe immer es passt hier ist
und welche berlin bin ins historische
museum fehlen also in berlin auf jeden
fall das deutsche historische museum das
ist finde ich ein ganz großartiges und
den hamburger bahnhofs mag ich auch
gerne was kann ich empfehlen
na ja also es fällt mir schwer irgendein
literarischen schinken zu empfehlen oder
sowas aber ich kann auf jeden fall an
allen leuten empfehlen sich einfach mal
auszuprobieren selber anfangen zu malen
selber auf der bühne zu stehen und sich
einfach irgendwie auszudrücken und
festzustellen dass kunst klein selber
was ganz schönes und bedeutsames sein
kann
für die sehr abwechslungsreich also
an der ecke kann er zu kurz wir wollen
im pergamonmuseum
besonders spektakulär ist dort ja dass
ich traktor gerade angesprochen ich
werde im sommer nach paris gehen und wir
sprachen darüber dass das museum ein
toller aufenthaltsort ist und erzählte
von schnüre diesem schritt stelle der
eine sehr schöne novellensammlung
geschrieben hat als vaters bart noch rot
war und darin beschreibt er
der protagonist ich erzähle wie eben der
vater arbeitslos eigentlich im
naturkundemuseum angestellt als aufsicht
mit ihm immer im winter ins museum
gegangen ist um sich aufzuwärmen
sie hatten kein geld nirgends und zwar
keine zu hause und es ist sehr anrührend
und ja museum ist also einen
aufenthaltsort ein lebensraum für mich
berlin hat ganz viel zu bieten an museen
wir haben also ein museumspass mit dem
wir ein jahr lang kostenlos und jedes
staatliche museum gehen können und das
tun wir auch relativ häufig jens ist
zurück
ihr wart ihr heute an einem besonderen
ort wobei der wir waren
auf der museumsinsel hier in berlin es
war sehr schön
die museumsinsel ist ein besonderer ort
es ist keine kleine insel in der spree
und dort gibt es besonders viele museen
gab es eine spannende antwort eine kurze
antwort aber sehr schön war kunst ist
freiheit auch sehr cool kann man
unterschreiben kann man zustimmen
hast du noch einen tipp für unsere
zuschauer ja war ich habe eine karte
einen moment ist es realistisch nur 25
euro und man kann diese karte kaufen und
jahreskarte der staatlichen museen zu
berlin fielen
wenn dir diese karte habt also das
machst du oft ins museum gehen ja man
kann für eine ganze jahr die als
statistin museen sehen sehr guter tipp
wenn ihr in berlin seit und vielleicht
hier wohnt ja liebe zuschauer das war
schon für die episode heute danken es
ihr habt gelernt was leute wie leute
kunst empfinden wenn ihr lust habt auf
meridianen
dann abonniert unbedingt unseren kanal
hier unten seht ihr die german
abonnieren und wenn ihr lust habt unser
projekt zu unterstützen und auch extra
outtakes und extras zu bekommen zum
beispiel von den fragen die leute auf
die straße gestellt hat dann werdet
mitglied bei uns bei ferien danke fürs
zuschauen und bis bald wieder lance
bitte wir hoffen du kommst noch mal
wieder ja ich freue mich auf ciao